This June, Netflix is boosting the quantity
and quality of their streaming selections.
They're rolling out nearly three dozen new
original movies and shows, including the hotly
anticipated second seasons of Luke Cage and
GLOW along with the series finale of cult
hit Sense8.
Plus, look for brand new action-packed blockbusters
to land on the streaming service this month.
Here's everything coming to Netflix in June
2018, starting with all the Netflix originals.
Busted!
Season Finale
Netflix's off-the-wall Korean detective comedy
Busted! premiered throughout May, with each
Friday seeing the release of two new episodes.
Viewers have had plenty of time to get invested
in this motley crew of celebrity detectives
as they work to gather clues and unravel mysteries,
and June 1st heralds the arrival of the season
finale, finally bringing closure to all those
quirky antics.
November 13: Attack on Paris
November 13, 2015 was a tragic day in Paris.
Terrorists perpetrated a series of bombings
and mass shootings in the French capital that
ultimately took 130 lives.
To say that the horrific incidents affected
many in Paris would be an understatement,
and that's the focus of Netflix's documentary
series November 13: Attack on Paris.
Through three gripping episodes, the series
will explore the terrorist attacks and their
emotional aftermath through candid interviews
with French citizens as well as first responders.
Look for it on June 1st.
The Break with Michelle Wolf
Comedian Michelle Wolf's brand new sketch
comedy and late-night show premiered on May
27th, and will continue throughout June with
new episodes each week, starting on June 3rd.
Tune in every Sunday as Wolf sits down with
celebrity guests and takes shots at politics,
modern life, and everything in between.
Alex Strangelove
Alex is a high school boy with a perfect life
who decides that he's finally ready to go
all the way with his girlfriend.
But when he meets a boy who makes him question
everything, he realizes that his life may
not be so perfect after all.
Look for it on June 8th.
Ali’s Wedding
This award-winning Australian comedy-drama
follows a Muslim man named Ali who finds himself
caught between a rock and a hard place, or,
rather, caught between his family and the
woman he loves.
Starring comedian Osamah Sami and based on
Sami's own memoir, Ali's Wedding is sure to
be an emotional crowdpleaser.
Look for it to hit Netflix on June 8th.
Marcella: Season 2
This first season of this British detective
series aired to glowing reviews, and Netflix
picked up the international rights immediately.
Starring Anna Friel, Marcella is about a retired
detective who rejoins the force in a state
of personal crisis after her husband decides
to divorce her and take the kids.
After she picks up a 15-year-old murder investigation,
Marcella slowly finds that her own life may
be inextricably linked to the killer.
Season 2 of Marcella aired in Britain starting
in February 2018, and will be making its way
to Netflix on June 8th.
Sense8: The Series Finale
This Netflix original sci-fi series is practically
a legend at this point.
After two seasons, Netflix canceled Sense8
in 2017, claiming that it wasn't bringing
in enough viewers to justify its exorbitant
cost, rumored to be $9 million per episode
in Season 2.
"Someone tell me just what in the hell is
going on here?"
When the dust had all cleared, fans were left
with a massive cliffhanger and an insatiable
urge for more Sense8, leading to a flood of
online petitions to put the show back on the
air.
It seems like someone at Netflix has heard
the cries for more, and a two-hour series
finale is finally slated to land on Netflix
on June 8th.
The Staircase
In 2001, novelist Michael Peterson called
the police to report that his wife, Kathleen,
had fallen down the stairs.
The ensuing police investigation honed in
on Peterson as the prime suspect, and in 2003,
Peterson was sentenced to life in prison for
the crime.
"The injuries are not consistent with a fall
down the stairs."
Netflix's upcoming documentary series The
Staircase takes a deep dive into the details
of the controversial case.
Did Peterson do it?
Was it an accident?
Was she attacked by an owl?
Follow all the twists and turns when The Staircase
shows up on June 8th.
Lust Stories
This anthology series explores life and love
in India through the lenses of four different
filmmakers, each presenting a different film
about relationships, trust, and betrayal.
Basically, the title says it all!
Look for it on June 15th.
Maktub
An Israeli dramedy, this film sees two bumbling
criminals decide to change their lives after
surviving a terrorist bombing.
Armed with a new purpose in life, they set
out to make wishes come true, specifically,
by nabbing people's written prayers from Jerusalem's
wailing wall.
Together, they go on a chaotic journey as
they try to learn how to be good people.
Look for Maktub on June 15th.
Set It Up
Things get wild in Set It Up when two corporate
lackeys decide to try to get their high-strung
bosses to fall in love.
"When they're boning, we're free."
But when things inevitably go wrong with their
matchmaking plan, they start finding out that
they have more in common with each other than
they thought.
Set It Up premieres on Netflix on June 15th.
Sunday’s Illness
Described as an "aching, sweeping drama,"
Sunday's Illness is the emotional story of
a mother and her estranged daughter who spend
ten days at an isolated cabin together.
There, they slowly try to come to terms with
where their lives are now, and how things
could have been different.
Experience the whole journey when Sunday's
Illness arrives on June 15th.
The Ranch: Part 5
Netflix's sitcom The Ranch has fallen on some
hard times.
Following continued allegations against actor
and co-executive producer Danny Masterson,
Netflix decided to write Masterson's character
out of The Ranch and continue without him.
Still, the series is plowing ahead into its
third season, with Ashton Kutcher, Sam Elliott,
and Debra Winger reprising their roles.
The first part of the new season drops on
June 15th.
Club de Cuervos presents: The Ballad of Hugo
Sánchez
The Mexican drama Club de Cuervos doesn't
seem like it has the makings of a cult classic,
but give it a chance, because there are a
lot of good surprises here.
Centering on the brother and sister owners
of the Cuervos football club, the series is
a perfect mix of drama, crime, thrills, and
comedy.
Now, the series is producing its first spinoff,
which translates to The Ballad of Hugo Sanchez
and follows series regular Hugo Sanchez on
his own storyline within the Cuervos universe.
Take a look on June 17th.
Brain on Fire
Based on journalist Susannah Cahalan's autobiography
Brain on Fire: My Month of Madness, this film
follows the bizarre events which saw Cahalan
suffer an apparent mental breakdown that was
later diagnosed to be the symptoms of an autoimmune
disease.
Chloe Grace Moretz stars as Cahalan, with
an impressive list of co-stars that includes
Richard Armitage and Carrie-Anne Moss.
Don't miss Brain on Fire when it lands on
June 22nd.
Derren Brown: Miracle
Hot on the heels of his Netflix special The
Push, illusionist and mentalist Derren Brown
is back with Miracle.
This time, Brown is taking to the stage to
subtly poke fun at blind religious beliefs
even as he seemingly performs the same impossible
stunts that would push someone to believe
in a higher power in the first place.
"The Lord removes your ability to read.
Just so long enough to teach you a powerful
lesson about faith and belief."
It's sure to be a head trip, so tune in to
get your mind blown on June 22nd.
Heavy Rescue: 401: Season 2
Tow trucks, fire trucks, semi trucks, there
are big trucks everywhere in Heavy Rescue:
401.
If you were a kid who liked trucks and who
grew up to like trucks even more, you're bound
to love this show about trucks.
"There's the door of your transport truck.
Can I get my truck right here?"
Ride along with the guys who operate rescue
vehicles as they brave the harshest environment
imaginable: Ontario.
Season 2 revs into gear on June 22nd.
Marvel’s Luke Cage: Season 2
Can anyone believe it's been over a year and
a half since Season 1 of Luke Cage first arrived
on Netflix?
Time flies when you're in denial, but the
wait is finally over.
This time, Luke Cage is facing off against
the new villain Bushmaster.
The unbreakable hero is set to reappear on
Netflix on June 22nd.
Don't miss it.
Secret City
Filled with high-stakes thrills and political
intrigue, Secret City follows a journalist
who gets too close to the truth and uncovers
a web of conspiracies
Starring Anna Torv and Jacki Weaver, Netflix
describes this upcoming show as "dark and
cerebral," which sounds like a grand ol' time.
Look for it on June 26th.
GLOW: Season 2
Saturday night's alright for fightin' this
June, with an all-new season of the hit series
GLOW.
"We got a show to do.
What is this?"
The Gorgeous Ladies of Wrestling make their
triumphant return in the ring on June 29th.
Kiss Me First
In the near future, a young woman who's addicted
to a popular virtual reality game meets a
mysterious woman who shows her how dark the
game can actually get.
With a hook like that, there's no doubt that
Kiss Me First will turn out to be a popular
addition to Netflix's line-up.
Look for it on June 29th.
Nailed It!: Season 2
How many ways are there to bake a bad cake?
At least another season's worth, Nailed It:
Season 2 is preheating the oven for another
round of culinary monstrosities and the poor
folk who are just trying their best.
Take a bite on June 29th.
Recovery Boys
From Elaine McMillion Sheldon, director of
the Oscar-nominated documentary Heroin(e),
Recovery Boys takes a long, painful look into
the opioid epidemic, focusing on four men
who are struggling to recover from addiction
and reenter society.
Queue it up on June 29.
Tau
The sci-fi thriller Tau stars Maika Monroe,
Gary Oldman, and Ed Skrein.
The movie sees Skrein put on his Deadpool
pants again as shady supervillain Ajax - sorry,
Alex - who kidnaps a young grifter named Julia
and subjects her to a dangerous experiment.
Escape seems impossible, since she's being
guarded by Tau, an advanced artificial intelligence
developed by Alex.
Take a look on June 29th.
Original stand-up comedy
With only two new stand-up specials to boast
in June, Netflix is doubling down on quality
over quantity on the comedy front.
Both arrive late in the month - Hannah Gadsby:
Nanette shows up on the 19th, and a special
from W. Kamau Bell, which takes center stage
on the 26th.
That's it for the Netflix originals, now let's
turn to everything else arriving on Netflix
this June.
New movies
Netflix is blowing up the screen this June
with two of 2017's biggest action blockbusters
- Thor: Ragnarok, which sees Thor and the
Hulk teaming up to save Asgard from Hela.
and Star Wars: The Last Jedi.
Haven't seen them yet?
You'll get your chance when Thor arrives on
the 5th and The Last Jedi shows up on the
26th.
"What's the matter with you?
You're embarrassing me.
I told them we were friends."
Plus, relive some of the decade's best dramas
with The Departed arriving on June 1, The
King's Speech on June 2, and The Imaginarium
of Doctor Parnassus on June 15, followed by
Martin McDonagh's irreverent 2008 crime comedy
In Bruges on the 16th.
"If I'd grown up on a farm and was retired.
Bruges might impress me, but I didn't, so
it doesn't."
In the mood for lighter fare?
Netflix is opening the month with some great
new romantic comedies.
On the first, look for Nick and Norah's Infinite
Playlist, Rumor Has It, and Just Friends.
"Chris!
Chris!"
"I'm busy!"
Also on the first, keep your eyes peeled for
the 2015 documentary He Named Me Malala, a
gripping look at the life of the youngest
Nobel laureate in history.
Finally, Netflix isn't scaring up a ton of
new thrills this month, but there are a few
gems hiding in the mix.
June 1st will see the addition of Taking Lives,
The Covenant, and The Boy, a selection guaranteed
to keep you up all night.
New television
You'll be glued to the TV this June as plenty
of new seasons of fan favorite shows join
the Netflix roster.
Season 2 of Wynonna Earp drops on June 9th,
Season 8 of Portlandia on June 10th, and on
June 16th, hold on tight for the emotional
final season of Grey's Anatomy.
Plus, be sure to check out the first season
of Marlon Wayans' new sitcom Marlon on the
14th.
Finally, Supergirl Season 3 and iZombie Season
4 are slated to arrive once they finish airing
on the CW, and Marvel's Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
drops its 5th season on June 17th.
That's a whole lot of excitement for one month.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!